you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme a lack of basic energy
efficiency measures is costing
households more in fuel bills and
putting net zero targets at risk
the royal thai navy is racing to contain
an oil spill off the eastern coast of
thailand before it reaches land
and how cardboard creations could help
the film industry go greener
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions now almost 13 million homes
are lacking basic energy efficiency
measures which could save households up
to 70 pounds a year and save the planet
more than 4 million tons in carbon
emissions analysis of energy performance
certificate data also known as epcs
shows a few simple steps could help cut
emissions from our homes which account
for 22 percent of all greenhouse gas
emissions and keep the government's net
zero targets in sight
epcs rate a building from a to g with a
being the most efficient it reflects how
much it might cost to heat and power
your home and its likely greenhouse gas
emissions the government has set targets
for all homes to be given an epc rating
of c by 20 35
currently 16.8 million uk homes are
missing that very target and here's why
2.2 million of those homes lack basic
insulation on hot water cylinders having
that could reduce emissions by 400 000
tons
6.4 million homes either lack or could
improve their heating controls which
could save around 1.8 million tonnes in
emissions and close to 11 million
households are yet to switch some of
their lighting to energy efficient light
bulbs which could save 1.9 million
tonnes of emissions
every year well joining me now is the
chief executive of camera the company
that collected that data all the shields
thank you so much for your time all 11
million homes haven't made that switch
yet to energy efficient light bulbs
i mean what's stopping people from
making that change do you think
um i think there's a lot of factors at
play here um i think there's a basic
lack of awareness that housing is one of
the biggest contributors um to uk
emissions and costing people a lot of
money that it doesn't have to
uh so residential properties account for
22
of all
uh emissions across the uk
and um it isn't as simple and as
straightforward as uh in introducing a
step like banning petrol in petrol
engines as it is in the transport
industry so um we're kind of at the very
beginning of our journey with housing
and and i think there needs to be a lot
of education around the fact that these
simple steps can be taken uh so with it
it is staggering that 11 million almost
11 million properties
don't have energy efficient light bulbs
and some of our senses that some of the
fixtures and fittings need to change
around that but our main um feeling is
that
there needs to be more education around
around this topic um if you look at some
of the really simple measures that um
you just went through there ashna uh
stuff like draft proofing can save four
hundred thousand tons that's a that's
draft proofing is just plugging holes
around your house that are letting cold
water in um uh sorry cold air in and um
uh warm air out and so at that a little
step in your house can make a huge
difference
uh some other things um that um aside
from energy efficient fitting and energy
efficient light bulbs which is a really
cheap and simple tip that you can impact
and is um looking at your thermostat
controls uh so as you mentioned 6.4
million
uh properties either lack or need to
improve their thermostat controls and
being able to regulate the temperature
in your house can have a massive impact
but you could also start with something
as basic as turning off radiators in um
in rooms that you're not using and these
are all really simple steps um but if we
collectively approach this problem with
this mindset we can actually
collectively save a lot of money and but
also
even more importantly reduce the carbon
footprint
of the property industry
thank you very much an oil slick off the
coast of thailand is continuing to
expand and is now approaching beaches on
the country's east coast the leak from
an undersea pipe leaked tens of
thousands of litres of fuel into the
ocean before it was stopped there are
now two slicks one is less than half a
square mile but the other is around 18
square miles the largest is expected to
reach the coast this evening and enter a
national park which is home to hundreds
of seabirds and fish the royal thai navy
is working to contain the spill so the
oil can be removed before this happens
our southeast asia correspondent siobhan
robbins has more
well this leak happened on tuesday at a
mooring station in the gulf of thailand
and it's estimated 60 000 liters of oil
have now leaked into the sea and for the
last four days the thai authorities have
had ships out helicopters planes and
also got help from experts in malaysia
to try and contain this spill and one of
the things they've been doing is
spraying special chemicals on the water
to try and break that oil down now one
of the main focuses today is a concern
that the oil is heading towards the
shore with it potentially washing up on
beaches any time this evening so they've
been really trying to contain it and the
navy has said that they've got 300
personnel on the shore ready to collect
any oil that does spill they put out
special boys also to try and protect the
shoreline and there's a big concern
about the potential impact on the coral
in this area because it's actually a
national park area as well as the fact
that those beaches are exceptionally
popular with tourists now the slightly
positive news today from the navy is
that the oil does seem to have become
thinner on the service surface it is
still moving and the thai authorities
have confirmed that the government has
filed a police complaint
well meanwhile in peru authorities are
dealing with the aftermath of an oil
spill on the 15th of january which is
believed to be linked to the eruption of
an underwater volcano near tonga dead
seals birds and fish have washed up on
the coast covered in oil hundreds of
volunteers are helping the extensive
cleanup peruvian president pedro
castillo called it the biggest
ecological disaster to affect the south
american nation in recent years
well now some of the day's other climate
news for you and the government's autumn
spending package has been deemed a
missed opportunity by environmental
campaigners the wwf says 55 billion
pounds of rishi sunax budget announced
just before cop 26 undermines climate
goals and drives up emissions a net zero
test run by the charity said overall the
package which includes investment in new
roads and the cut to air passenger duty
is expected to increase greenhouse gas
emissions by 38 million tons over the
next four years
more than 80 people have been killed by
tropical storm anna across southern and
eastern africa in the last few days
intense rainfall has caused widespread
flooding with buildings collapsing
across madagascar malawi and mozambique
hundreds of thousands of people have
been affected experts say that storms in
the regions are becoming more frequent
as waters warm due to climate change
the national trust has announced its
first green corridor will be in bath
inspired by the georgian pastime of
spending time in the countryside it will
link the city to the hills that surround
it it's the first of 20 corridors
planned by the conservation charity
designed to connect urban areas in
england wales and northern ireland to
green spaces
the australian government has pledged
704 million dollars over the next nine
years to save the great barrier reef of
the funding more than 400 million
dollars will go towards remedying
erosion on the australia's northeastern
coast the rest will support the green
barrier reef marine park authority and
go towards research into making the reef
more resilient to the effects of climate
change
now from plastic bottles on set to paper
scripts throw away props and a lot of
travel the film industry isn't known for
its green credentials is it but many
production companies are now focused on
reducing waste cutting emissions and
making the business more sustainable one
studio boss in manchester is making
great strides towards a greener method
of filmmaking by using cardboard sets
fraser moored has the details
and finally here at the vector studios
in manchester we are in the world of
film and television looks can be
deceiving
take this tudor house for example made
without using any wood metal or stone it
is in fact
cardboard
it's 80 cheaper than a traditional wood
or mdf set it has a carbon footprint
that's 90 percent lower
and it's 100 recyclable as i found out
on the hogwarts express the film
industry in this country has grown 400
in the last 10 years and it's still
growing we've got peter jackson people
want to bring productions over here
we've got netflix we've got all these
things
we're short of resources
that's the reality so the first thing is
how do you address the shortage in
resources and this does
the cardboard comes from sustainably
harvested trees in sweden and once the
team has turned it into stone or steel
or concrete or whatever it arrives on
set as flat packs so we're standing in a
kitchen where everything is cardboard
from the floor to the granite work
surfaces to the metal cooker hood there
how do you do it well we're using a
variety technique so it's based on our
vector board which is incredibly strong
for paper and it's equivalent to mdf
and we can do lots of things with it so
we can machine cut it we can hand cut it
we use hand building techniques and
fairly traditional kind of theater and
film
finishing technique scenic techniques
but we can also do it the digital side
so we can print tiles we can print
kitchens and this comes as a digital
file that we can change
the sets weigh a fraction of their
wooden equivalents meaning build times
and transport costs are greatly reduced
you know i can imagine that cardboard
film sets could be easier to make easier
to take down easier to store away
afterwards and reuse for other purposes
like you know i can imagine there could
be all kinds of benefits and it's just
taken a bit of creativity from someone
to get it off the ground
and that creativity is happening here on
an industrial estate in manchester
the time and cost savings along with the
incredible realism should mean that
convincing production companies to adopt
cardboard sets shouldn't be too hard to
sell
the film and television industries have
been encouraged for some time to reduce
their environmental impact in the future
it could be humble cardboard that offers
at least part of the solution
fraser moored sky news manchester
more on those sets later in the show now
climate change isn't just affecting the
ocean's living organisms but also
historical treasures hidden under the
sea marine archaeologists are now
worried that shipwrecks and other
artifacts are being damaged by warming
waters and changing weather
[Music]
well with the case of invincible and
many other
shipwrecks in the uk they're located in
shallow coastal waters so they're
affected by the physical environment so
that's
tides currents and wave action
[Music]
and this is allowing those marine boring
organisms
to thrive and breed and multiply
and feed on the exposed parts of the
wrecks
[Music]
the danger is that we're losing
huge amounts of on the water cultural
heritage you know stormier weather
conditions or exposing these shipwrecks
they're then becoming more vulnerable to
the physical biological and
chemical processes
[Music]
do stay tuned coming up here on the
daily climate show i'll be joined by
artist environmental activist and
honorary president of the black
environment network judy ling wong and
editor-in-chief at business screen james
murray we'll be discussing if last
year's autumn spending review was a
missed opportunity for climate action
and if the film industry can really go
green
[Applause]
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day with artist
and honorary president of the black
environment network judy linguang and
editor-in-chief at business screen james
murray thank you both very much for
joining us starting with then the report
by wwf that says the autumn spending
review announced just before cop 26
undermines climate girls and drives up
emissions the charity run a zero net
zero test which found the spending
package is expected to increase
greenhouse gas emissions over the next 4
years i should say and so is this a
missed opportunity by the government
we're asking james were you surprised to
read this report
not at all with the conclusions i think
when the spending package was initially
announced in the autumn the immediate
reaction from a lot of green groups and
a lot of green businesses was it did
feel like a missed opportunity it was
there just before cop 26. uh the
government had its net zero strategy um
sort of imminent and was planning to
sort of explain more clearly how it
intended to decarbonize the economy
fully within less than 30 years uh and
then the the speech came out from russia
sunaki barely mentioned climate change
and and the need to transition to net
zero uh and he did announce these
measures of increased spending on on
roads and uh sort of a lower taxes on
air passenger duty and on flights so you
know there's some good stuff in there as
well it's true the government is doing a
lot to drive forward um innovation and
deployment in areas like offshore wind
electric vehicles you know it's not fair
to say the government's doing nothing on
this front
but that particular budget felt like it
could have been a lot bolder
particularly when also we need economic
stimulus you know we were still coming
out at the back end of the the lockdowns
then the pandemic impact that we've had
has still been
severe on the economy um as a whole
and there is an opportunity here to
build back greener as the prime minister
had it
um before he started slightly dropped
that phrase in in more recent times um
and and that yeah yeah that budget felt
like a moment when you really could be
more ambitious and start to drive
forward some of these investments we
need to see in areas like energy
efficiency hydrogen carbon capture and
storage smart grids
and various other areas so uh yeah i
think a missed opportunity from this the
wws conclusion i think a lot of people
will agree i'll pick your brains on
renewables in a second uh james but judy
we saw those big climate commitments
didn't we
after cop 26. um does some of that
package that was announced by the
chancellor undermine that the wwf is
saying 55 billion pounds of that could
drive up emissions
it is really important for us to give an
image of absolute ambitious support for
the movements into the future because
after a lot of people don't realize it
but the cop 26 presidency is ongoing
until cop 27 is in place we are in one
of the big driving seats for actions or
climate emergency so we need to be
ambitious seem to put massive amounts of
needed money in that direction and be an
example for others to lead the way as
james says it's not that we don't do
things that are
and in a way quite important for example
the green jobs initiative where the
government is investing in green jobs
and hopes to put in another 2 million
jobs by 2030. that's a good initiative
but it's the overall ambition that has
to come out right for climate emergency
there is that targeted investment from
the government though james isn't there
you mentioned it earlier in the form of
wind energy but there is this huge
support for renewables that is coming
pretty quickly isn't it
yeah i mean the government's done a lot
on on offshore wind in particular and it
was around that time they announced the
next wave of funding to support the next
wave of offshore wind farms recently
we've seen
scottish um the the scottish crown
estate announcing that it's gonna lease
more of the seabed for offshore win so
you know there's been huge progress on
that front and that will continue uh and
also we're starting to see sort of
onshore renewables come back online as
well so we are seeing that progress what
is sometimes missed about this though is
is the sheer scale of what's required is
much larger than many people
anticipate or understand if we are to
fully decarbonize and get gas and coal
off the grid as completely pretty much
unabated gas and coal off the grid
completely within the space of only
about 15 years
then you just need renewables at truly
massive scale and you need them as
quickly as possible and the economic
arguments for them have fallen away
because they're increasingly cost
competitive i mean you know there are
cheaper than gas in many ways on a
levelized basis currently and we're also
seeing the cost of energy storage
systems fall and and we're starting to
see really exciting work going on in
hydrogen as well where you could start
to produce hydrogen using excess
renewable generation
capacity so
we just it's it's the thing where
everything's pointing towards we need to
be doing this at scale and we need to be
doing it really fast and any potential
barriers that stand in the way whether
that's the government not being as
ambitious as it could be in terms of the
contracts it's providing or planning
constraints or the like um it needs to
tear those barriers down as quickly as
possible if we're to meet the
overarching goals
and again the you know that budget and
and the last few months have been a real
opportunity around cop 26 and post cop26
to do that and
we're just not seeing the pace of change
that's required uh at this time and lots
of businesses are waiting they're ready
they've got the capital they want to
invest they just need to get this
pipeline of projects moving as swiftly
as physically possible
and judy just very quickly you mentioned
green jobs but there is still a lot of
upskilling to do right for people to
retrain and really get there
yes i mean for example the government
has put in good initiatives to put in
new and adapted apprenticeship standards
in order to fill this skills gap that we
have and that is very good it's all
about a lot of us about where we are
confident about where the money is
coming from and as you know a lot of
government money comes from our taxes
and because of the way a lot of rich
people do not end up paying taxes a lot
of middle class and working class people
have to foot the bill i like to see
government braver in texting the rich i
mean only last week 102
millionaires came together and said
texas i mean that's a brush of fresh air
isn't it to see that coming from rich
people saying they want a greater role
in funding things and i think that's
very welcome we can hear a little bit
more on the green economy in this week's
episode of sky news climate cast where
we hear from people who have made the
transition as judy was saying from a
high carbon career to a low carbon one
all in the name of climate change do you
take a listen wherever you get your
podcast from next guys let's move on
earlier we were talking about production
teams in manchester using cardboard sets
to lower their impact on the environment
but the average film is responsible for
500 tons of co2 judy should hollywood
introduce stricter rules when it comes
to um you know setting example and
cutting back on emissions or actually do
you think do you know what we hear so
much about climate change let's not
touch the hollywood blockbusters because
we need that that net respite i suppose
they can still make just as much money
when they actually put some effort into
being greener i mean for one thing you
can be sure about hollywood they're
image sensitive and in that way ordinary
citizens have some power when we start
to make certain ways of living and doing
things unacceptable that has a huge
effect on that image and i think that
they should now start to state their
intent as an industry and within the
actors electricians themselves to say we
will commit to this and start cutting
all sorts of things going right through
the things they do from how they travel
to the materials they use the energy
they use in that building is it
renewable and so just go through the
whole list and
just show off what they can do to us
james just a quick thought from you do
you think carbon budgets could be the
way to go
it's really difficult to assign a carbon
budget specifically to an industry but
where the kind of having a net zero
target for an economy as a whole is so
important is it does encompass everyone
so there's no industry that can ignore
it and say no we're not going to
decarbonize you'll have to you know
hollywood's in california california has
a big net zero target we've got a huge
film industry in the uk and the uk has a
net zero target and of course all the
the producers are responding to that i
mean obviously yourselves at sky have a
net zero goal the bbc has a net zero
goal netflix has a really ambitious net
zero goal that they're looking to pursue
as well um and what i think is
particularly exciting about the film
industry is it's inherently a very
creative and technologically innovative
space so you are starting to see
projects where outside broadcasts are
saying we're going to ditch diesel
generators and switch to hydrogen fuel
cells you've seen projects like the sort
of resource efficiency that you were
showing earlier about switching to
cardboard sets um and and it's also a
really influential industry and it can
inform its viewers and it can inform its
stakeholders and its suppliers crucially
to say you know we're part of the net
zero transition we want it to accelerate
we want to see these clean technologies
so i'm a bit low to sort of advocate for
a specific carbon budget for one
industry at a time because you end up
getting quite distorting effects in the
economy as a whole
but every industry from hollywood down
absolutely has to
respond to this necessity to fully
decarbonize within the space of less
than 30 years which will be
the fastest and most exciting and most
consequential industrial revolution in
human history
we will see thank you very much james
murray and judy ling wong thank you for
your time just before we go on monday
we'll be joined by host of climate
curious podcast and director of tedx
london marion pascha and director of the
conservative environment network sam
hall thank you very much for watching
see you next time
[Music]